hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 9 video
one more week till the mid-season finale
so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet if you've
been a fan of Joss Whedon shows for a
long time you may have recognized the
familiar twist with Coulson and Rollins
character but I'm also gonna talk a
little bit about kilgrave's character on
Jessica Jones when I talk about Warren's
character so starting with top 5 WTF
number 5 roselyn's character gets fridge
in service of Coulson's character
development
so maybe been a long time since you guys
have seen Buffy but it did a very
similar thing with the Giles character
who's kind of like the Coulson of that
show he gets into this relationship and
a former friend ends up killing her to
strengthen Giles resolve to take the
Giles character in a really hardcore
direction so that's basically what
happened with Coulson's character now on
Buffy it was the angel character and I
don't necessarily think that Ward is the
angel of agents of shield
I think he's closer to Spike right now
but pushing Buffy aside it's just it's
fun to think about Buffy when you think
about other Joss Whedon shows even
though agents of shield technically is
not a Joss Whedon show
it's his younger brother and his wife
that are the show runners but Whedon
versus Whedon versus Whedon bursts so if
you guys actually want to go back and
watch those old episodes of Buffy those
were from like the first two seasons
that Jenny calendar character the thing
we need to talk about though is
roselyn's character like what's gonna
happen now that she's gone she was one
of the best new characters as they
brought on this season I was so pissed
when they killed her off but I mean I
totally understand like they want to
take Coulson in this hardcore direction
but it's kind of at the expense of this
really awesome character of all the
things the agents of shield has been
doing really well this season I feel
like some of its best material that has
come from these Coulson Rosalind moments
so now that we don't have that any more
I'm kind of defaulting to Fitz and
Simmons is like the go-to team shield
itself as a team but there's always
going to be teams within teams like now
we even have Daisy's secret warriors so
anima number 4 WTF Daisy secret warriors
actually becomes a thing but it's only a
team of three and it's just Joey and
Lincoln so they're finally paying this
off like Daisy's finally getting to go
into action I'll be with slightly
unstable Lincoln Joey seems like he's
really up for the task though I liked
the moment with May's character where
she's like I don't know if Andrew was
being honest or if flash made this
character assessment for Lincoln they're
just saying that Lincoln could fly off
the handle so there might be some
collateral damage but I feel like
depending on where they leave things in
the mid seas
finale they could be doing a lot more
secret Warriors related stuff in the
back half of the season it seems like
that's the intention because they have
this inhuman army that hydras been
trying to assemble in this mystery
inhuman King that they're trying to
bring back so of course to fight powers
you need more powers and that's where
secret warriors comes in so yeah you
know everybody shake their fist secret
warriors on the my number 3 WTF Ward
completes his journey to the dark side
now they still kind of want to make him
sympathetic because they roll out his
brother late in the episode they did
kind of feel like it came out of nowhere
but I love doing Coulson's
interrogations of the shield team
members how Daisy talked about how Ward
attaches himself to powerful father
figures so that's where it powers Boothe
you know with the Gideon Malick
character comes in on the show he's like
Ward's new dad this is where we get to
the ward killgrave persona because
they're both Psychopaths for slightly
different reasons like they both have
different backstories but they're acting
out in very similar ways like the Gideon
Malick character has to tell work think
about the big picture
revenge is petty closure is overrated
think about the big picture we'll be
able to do anything we want doesn't that
just sound like a conversation that
someone needs to have with kilgrave look
you can control people's minds
forget about Jessica Jones and think
about the big picture
the kilgrave in war both have these
giant holes inside their souls that
they're trying to fill something that's
missing that they're trying to replace
with other relationships
maybe it's the childhood or the family
they felt they never had kilgrave thinks
that jessica jones is going to complete
his life give him everything that he
thought he'd never had Ward tried to do
that with Daisy's character he is
clearly hung up on Coulson as a dad
figure which is why he's trying to hurt
him so bad he did the exact same thing
with his real-life dad which his younger
brother talks about our dad was in a
wheelchair who is he gonna hurt why did
you need to kill him so the real
question is it's like where does the
word character go from here I think a
lot of that will depend on what goes
down in the mid-season finale because
the setup that they want you to buy into
is that Hydra has control on this other
planet they're gonna bring this big
inhuman back he's super evil and he's
gonna let Hydra do whatever they want
now that feels like it's way too easy so
I'm expecting a couple twists but there
are a couple really obvious twists that
I don't want to immediately buy into
like Oh what if this mystery inhuman
King is an evil and he
turns on Hydra like that would be the
obvious reveal so I'm not expecting that
either usually what you find with really
powerful ministry figures like the
vision is a good example in Avengers age
of Ultron is that they have a will of
their own and they'll form temporary
alliances like vision doesn't completely
swear fealty to Tony Stark but he's like
look you guys are better than Ultron so
I'm gonna help you defeat Ultron because
that's the logical outcome the
implication being that if the Avengers
were to do something that vision did not
buy into he would turn on them so I'm
expecting the same type of treatment
from this really powerful inhuman figure
whatever he or she turns out to be
they're probably not gonna be bound by
this Hydra value system so if you're
gonna expect anything just expect a lot
of collateral damage like Hydra will
suffer a lot of losses shield will
suffer a lot of losses on to my number
two WTF speaking of losses Coulson goes
to dark Coulson I'm gonna have to go
off-book
he passes directorship of shield to Mack
who probably isn't the best person for
the job so we'll see how that goes but
he kind of goes a little bit Doctor Who
with his plan there was this moment from
a Doctor Who episode last week where the
companion Clara said dr. 101 talk your
enemies into their own trap doctor 102
never tell anyone your real plan now
that's where the similarity ends because
that Doctor Who story ends in like a
very very different way than I think
that shield is gonna end at any time the
lead character is very open about not
telling anyone their plans or misleading
people I just I think of Doctor Who rule
number one the doctor lies and Coulson
kind of is the doctor of agents of
shield like he always has some secret
plan some way to win in the end
something that he's not telling you and
like the doctor Coulson just jumps into
the mouth of hell without even thinking
twice so Coulson is now in that foreign
planet I know it looks like he's knocked
out but he'll totally wake up if finally
out of my number one WTF Fitz throws
himself into the fire for Simmons so
like I said I've been invested in them
from day one like that you know they
tease that very early on in season 1
even though they've kind of taken their
time getting there so anytime they twist
the relationship knife you know when
they pick characters against each other
this is really where you feel it the
most just because they've taken so much
time to develop those characters in
their relationship if it wasn't clear
Fitz said that he was gonna just try and
bring back will he try and prevent the
inhuman from coming back to but the
problem with that if they spent so much
time developing this mystery powerful
figure
I don't think that they would completely
throw that plot away in the midseason
finale so I kind of do feel like this
mystery figure will make it back to
earth like they wouldn't set him up for
so long and then not pay that off but
the twist I'm expecting is that it just
won't go like Hydra expects it to go and
would it not be hilarious if Ward got
trapped on that planet like he replaced
will as the person trapped on the planet
I will laugh so hard at they end up
doing that but let me know in the
comments what was your guy's favorite
moment from the episode and what don't
you think about Coulson and Roslyn I
feel like them sitting down for Burgers
was the most relatable thing this season
on the show just like two normal
characters trying to share dinner
together trying to have a burger why is
it that everything called all-american
is terrible for you I'm gonna miss that
witty banter so hard so even if you
don't agree with some of the plot twists
in the episode I feel like some of these
characters they're doing really really
well
Coulson Rosslyn Fitz Simmons and I'll
say the new character that I'm also
really really excited about is Joey like
we've seen so little from him and I feel
like there's a lot of potential and I
really like what the actor is doing with
that character so what's gonna happen
next is agents of shield midseason
finale next week she goes down on the
foreign planet we'll probably get some
really good answers about that mystery
in human figure hopefully we'll get to
see them make landfall on earth and it
will go crazy secret warriors for the
rest of the season tonight is huge
though there is a full trailer for
Batman vs Superman coming and there is
the second part of the big arrow flash
crossover I'll be doing videos for both
of those be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'll just post them in the order that
they finish but you guys can follow me
on Twitter and Facebook for updates on
when videos are gonna post it all be
happening later tonight why you guys
continue all your internal screaming you
can click here for the arrow flash
crossover video from last night and you
can click here for my Captain America
civil war trailer all my other Avengers
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you